A speaker like Dr. Zakir Naik can only seem
persuasive in an atmosphere of ignorance.
Put him in a room full of people who’ve
carefully studied the Bible and the Qur’an,
and they will laugh him off the stage.
Watch what happens when we take a closer look
at one of Naik’s claims.
According to Naik, Jesus prophesied the coming
of Muhammad in the Book of John, Chapter 14,
Verse 16:
It’s further mentioned in the Gospel of
John, Chapter Number 14, verse number 16,
Jesus Christ (Peace Be Upon Him) says: “I
will pray to my Father, to send you another
Comforter, who will abide with you forever.”
Let’s go ahead and read the verse—John
14:16.
Jesus says:
“I will ask the Father, and He will give
you another Helper, that He may be with you
forever.”
Notice that Jesus refers to the Father here.
Do Muslims refer to Allah as “Father”?
No they don’t, because according to the
Qur’an, Allah is a Father to no one.
So even before we consider the meaning of
the verse, we see that it already contradicts
Islam.
But we’ll let Naik slide on that one, because
he’s about to thoroughly expose Muhammad
as a false prophet.
Explain the verse for us, Dr. Naik.
Jesus Christ (Peace Be Upon Him) says in the
Gospel of John, Chapter Number 14, verse Number
16, that I will pray to My Father to send
you another Comforter, who will abide with
you forever.
That means Jesus Christ (Peace Be Upon Him)
will not abide with the Christians forever.
This new Comforter, this new prophet who will
come, will abide with you forever.
So the verse is talking about a prophet.
That’s interesting.
The verse doesn’t say anything about a prophet.
But that’s what Dr. Naik is for—to tell
us what Jesus really means.
Now, there are all kinds of things we could
say in response to Naik’s interpretation
here.
We could point out that he’s defending Muhammad
by quoting a book that opens with a clear
declaration of the deity of Christ.
“In the beginning was the Word, and the
Word was with God, and the Word was God.
He was in the beginning with God.
All things came into being through Him, and
apart from Him nothing came into being that
has come into being.”
So all created things came into being through
the Word.
What else did the Word do?
Verse 14:
“And the Word became flesh, and dwelt among
us, and we saw His glory, glory as of the
only begotten from the Father, full of grace
and truth.”
This is referring, of course, to Jesus.
That’s how the Gospel of John begins.
Towards the end of the Gospel of John, Jesus’
Apostle Thomas calls him “My Lord and my
God!”
The Book of John also proclaims Jesus’ death
and resurrection.
Strange book for Muslims to go to when they
try to convince people that Islam is true.
That’s where the atmosphere of ignorance
comes in handy.
But we’ll ignore all of that.
We could also point out that in the very chapter
Naik is quoting, Jesus says:
“I am the way, and the truth, and the life;
no one comes to the Father but through Me.”
Odd.
Three of Allah’s ninety-nine names are “the
Way,” “the Truth,” and “the Living.”
But let’s pretend that Jesus doesn’t apply
the names of Allah to himself in the chapter
Naik quotes.
We could note that right there in the chapter
Naik quotes, Jesus claims that he can answer
prayers.
He tells his followers that he’s returning
to the Father, and He says:
“Whatever you ask in My name, that will
I do, so that the Father may be glorified
in the Son.”
What’s that?
Father and Son, and the Son is going to answer
the prayers of the apostles?
Is this sounding like Islam yet?
Certainly not, but we can ignore all of this.
Naik tells us that the Helper—the Comforter—is
Muhammad.
What else does Jesus say about the Comforter?
Well, Jesus immediately identifies the Helper
as “the Spirit of truth.”
Was Muhammad a spirit, according to Islam?
Jesus says that the world cannot receive the
Spirit “because it does not see Him.”
Was Muhammad invisible, according to Islam?
Jesus says to his first-century followers:
“But you know Him . . .” Did they know
Muhammad? “. . . because He abides with
you . . .” Muhammad abided with Jesus’
first-century followers? “. . . and will
be in you.”
Was Muhammad in Jesus’ first-century followers?
Doesn’t sound anything like Muhammad.
But guess what.
You can show all of this to one of Zakir Naik’s
fans and ask, “Is there any way this can
be referring to Muhammad?”
And he’ll respond, with a straight face,
“Yes, it’s obviously talking about Muhammad.
Muhammad is the only person Jesus could possibly
be talking about here.”
So instead of banging our heads against the
impenetrable wall of ignorance and stupidity
that Naik has built around the minds of his
followers, let’s just agree with him . . . for
the sake of argument.
Let’s pretend that Jesus was actually talking
about Muhammad in John 14:16.
We can’t get any more generous than that,
can we?
Amazingly, even when we’re as generous as
we can possibly be, Naik still ends up refuting
Islam and supporting Christianity.
How so?
Well, Naik doesn’t just quote what Jesus
says about the Comforter in John 14:16.
He also quotes what Jesus says in John 16:7.
What does Jesus say there, Dr. Naik?
It’s further mentioned in the Gospel of
John, Chapter Number 16, Verse Number 7, Jesus
Christ (Peace Be Upon Him) says: “Nevertheless,
I tell you the truth, it is expedient for
you that I go away.
For if I go not away the Comforter shall not
come.
For if I depart, shall I send Him.”
What did Jesus say?
“For if I depart, shall I send Him.”
Who sends the Comforter, according to Jesus?
“For if I depart, shall I send Him.
Shall I send Him.
Shall I send Him.”
Quick question for Muslims: Who sent Muhammad
as a prophet?
Any Muslim will be happy to say that Allah
sent Muhammad as a prophet.
So, according to Islam, Allah sent Muhammad.
Muhammad was sent by Allah.
Now, according to Jesus, and according to
Zakir Naik, because he quoted the verse as
an authoritative prophecy, who sends the Comforter?
I’ll remind you that Jesus says:
“But I tell you the truth, it is to your
advantage that I go away; for if I do not
go away, the Helper will not come to you;
but if I go, I will send Him to you.”
Who sends the Comforter?
Jesus does.
So Jesus sends the Comforter.
The Comforter is sent by Jesus.
Allah sends Muhammad.
Muhammad is sent by Allah.
If the Comforter is Muhammad, as Zakir Naik
claims, who does that make Jesus?
Hallelujah!
Thank you, Dr. Naik, for admitting that Jesus
is your God, and the God of Muhammad, and
the God of all Muslims.
Now, since Zakir Naik has proven, conclusively,
that Jesus is God, our Muslim friends are
faced with quite a dilemma.
Jesus is God, but the Qur’an says that Jesus
is not God.
This means one of two things.
Either Muhammad was not a true prophet, because
Muhammad delivered the Qur’an, which falsely
asserts that Jesus is not God; or Muhammad
was a true prophet, in which case he must
have originally proclaimed that Jesus is God,
only to have his revelations corrupted by
later Muslims.
So, according to Zakir Naik, either Muhammad
was a false prophet, or he was a true prophet,
but Muslims corrupted the book that he delivered.
Muslims don’t want to say that the Qur’an
has been corrupted, so we can only conclude
that Muhammad was a false prophet.
Since Muhammad was a false prophet, we can
ignore all of Zakir Naik’s nonsense about
the Comforter being Muhammad, and we can acknowledge
that the Comforter is the Holy Spirit.
But it gets better.
Because Jesus tells us more about the Holy
Spirit.
Jesus says, in John 15:26:
“When the Helper comes, whom I will send
to you from the Father, that is the Spirit
of truth who proceeds from the Father, He
will testify about Me.”
Here again, the Spirit is sent by Jesus.
But this is no ordinary Spirit.
This isn’t a created spirit.
This is the Spirit who proceeds from the Father.
And if the Spirit is in Jesus’ followers,
wherever they are, anywhere they go, even
if they travel across the universe, then the
Spirit has a divine attribute: omnipresence.
This reminds me of what King David said in
Psalm 139, verses 7 to 8:
“Where can I go from Your Spirit?
Or where can I flee from Your presence?
If I ascend to heaven, You are there;
If I make my bed in Sheol, behold, You are
there.”
If the Spirit has a divine attribute, then
the Spirit is divine.
And yet Jesus sends the Spirit.
Zakir Naik has already admitted that Jesus
is God, but now we have further proof.
Jesus sends the Spirit of God.
But how can God send the Spirit of God, which
proceeds from the Father?
It’s as if the Islamic view of God is too
simplistic to account for this.
And we find the same thing in the Old Testament.
In Isaiah 48:16, Yahweh (the God of Israel)
is speaking, and he says:
“Come near to Me, listen to this:
From the first I have not spoken in secret,
From the time it took place, I was there.
And now the Lord God has sent Me, and His
Spirit.”
So God says that he’s been sent by God,
along with the Spirit of God.
And yet the Bible consistently affirms that
there’s only one God.
And this goes all the way back to the very
first chapter of the Bible, where God says
in Genesis 1:26:
“Let Us make man in Our image, according
to Our likeness.”
Who’s God talking to?
He’s not talking to the angels.
The angels didn’t create man.
God created man.
And yet the one God who created man is somehow
plural.
God declared in the very first chapter of
the Bible that he is one in one sense, but
more than one in another sense.
And he gave us more and more insight into
his nature in the rest of the Bible.
By the time we get to the Book of John, we
can’t even understand what’s going on
without the doctrine of the Trinity.
And this is where Zakir Naik goes when he
wants to convince his listeners that Islam
is the true religion.
Now think about the utter incompetence of
Muslim apologists like Zakir Naik.
He tries to prove that Muhammad was a prophet
of God.
But as he tries to prove that Muhammad was
a prophet of God, he accidently proves that
Jesus is God, that God is a Trinity—Father,
Son, and Holy Spirit—and that Muhammad was
a false prophet.
Zakir Naik and Ahmed Deedat before him, spent
their lives deceiving their gullible and ignorant
listeners.
But as they spoke, they did get some important
Bible verses into the minds of their followers.
These verses are the seeds that we get to
water until Muslims recognize the truth about
Jesus.
One of the most important things we can do
is to draw out the logical implications of
the very passages Zakir Naik quotes, because
these passages prove that Muhammad was a false
prophet.
I’ve been doing this for a while.
If you want to see how some of Zakir Naik’s
other arguments actually turn out to insult
Muhammad, be sure to watch these videos.
And since we’ll be going through more Zakir
Naik clips in the coming months, be sure to
click the subscribe button so that you won’t
miss future updates on how Islam’s top apologists
are helping us refute Islam and defend the
Gospel.
God bless you.